depuis quelques temps j'ai remarqué un
truc j'ai de plus en plus la flemme de
débattre skis chelou ce que au début
c'était une flemme genre positive et que
ça devient de plus en plus une flemme
négative
je vais m'expliquer mais avant je
voulais vous parler de ce magnifique
t-shirt
c'est un tee shirt que je vous ai
concocté avec un pote il en précommande
brodé en france
coton bio je voulais un lien dans la
description rester jusqu'au bout puisque
je vous en parle à ce moment là c'est un
projet qui est assez important pour moi
qui est assez personnel et tous et c'est
une super manière de le soutenir
donc voilà rester jusqu'au bout et une
fois que la pré commande sera faite une
fois que le temps pré commande sera
passée il sera introuvable 1 3 je pense
que peut-être qui sera sur ebay à des
milliers d'euros peut-être dans quelques
années peut-être mais revenons-en à la
vidéo et vue qui fait un peu frisquet et
qu' il n'y a pas qu'un t-shirt ya aussi
un chouette
oui puisqu'on dit on dit souhaite une
passe witt je sais que les gens disent
oui tu vois hier sweet c'est souhaite
j'arrête de me justifier sur le fait que
c'est un chouette je vais le mettre
qu'est-ce qu'il est confortable world
si doux et si épais j'adore ça on est
bien là alors c'est quoi la flemme de
débattre et surtout c'est quoi ce délire
de flemme négative et flemme positive
je vais commencer par la flemme négative
parce que c'est celle que je viens en ce
moment et je pense que c'est elle qui
est partagée par le plus de gens quand
j'étais plus jeune j'adorais débattre je
débattais tout le temps de plein de
trucs et c'est parfois même je défends
des l'indéfendable juste par esprit de
contradiction
j'adorais ça et c'est normal débattre
c'est exercer une des plus belles choses
que l'on a la raison
le logos et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
c'est quelque chose qu'on adore regarder
aussi et depuis très longtemps déjà à
l'époque de l'antiquité on allait
regarder les rhéteurs un les adeptes de
la rhétorique et aujourd'hui les débats
télévisés politique ou quoi ont toujours
autant de succès quoi on adore regarder
ça c'est une joute verbale quoi c'est
presque un match âpre en parlais tout à
l'heure de raison de logos pour en
pratique il ya quand même pas mal de
passion voire même d'agressivité c'est
vrai
ça donne du piquant au match quoi
justement mais avec le temps j'ai de
moins en moins des battus je ne sais pas
j'ai l'impression que certaines valeurs
ont pris plus de place en moi comme par
exemple on était deux vis-à-vis de
soi-même tolérance ouverture à l'autre
et c est que plus ces valeurs prenait de
la place
- j'étais bon en débat c'est peut-être
un énorme raccourci en tout cas c'est ce
que je ressens dans tous les cas c'est
très perso et j'en tire absolument
aucune conclusion
donc je sais pas si c'est ça la raison
mais quoi qu'il en soit j'ai de moins en
moins des battues et aujourd'hui la
plupart du temps j'ai la flemme de
débattre quoi mais c'est pas georges
suis en train de débattre et puis ça me
lasse et j'ai la flemme
si j'ai la flemme avant même de
commencer à débattre alors je parle des
débats avec des gens qui sont
fondamentalement en désaccord avec vous
par exemple des gens qui pensent que le
réchauffement climatique n'existe pas si
si ça existe
voilà la cdpa où j'ai une flemme immense
mais je continue de débattre avec des
gens qui sont d'accord avec moi mais en
fait on n'est pas d'accord sur par
exemple des solutions ou de à quel point
un phénomène est avéré ce genre de
choses
il ya un gros socle commun quoi mais les
gens avec qui j'ai pas un gros socle
commun ça demande une telle énergie une
telle patience une telle dialectique
pour un gain en plus a priori faible
puisque il ya peu de chances que la
personne change d'avis après entre nous
je pense que le but soit qu'une des deux
personnes changent d'avis et soins
convaincu à la fin du débat
ya pas mal de thématiques sur lesquelles
je débattais ou à la fin du débat ont
changé pas à mon avis mais au fur et à
mesure mon opinion évolué et par exemple
j'étais plus à même de lire certains
articles que j'aurais pas lu avant et
donc petit à petit je me suis forgé une
opinion un peu différente mais c'était
pas à un débat qui m'a fait genre à la
fin du débat
waouh ah ouais tu as totalement raison
donc voilà je pense que vous voyez très
bien de quel flemme je parlais et
d'ailleurs vous êtes beaucoup à la
partager puisque j'ai fait un sondage
sur twitter et jean sur plus de 9000
votants et alors que 6 % de gens qui
n'ont jamais ressenti et la flemme de
débattre et plus de 40% qui ont très
souvent la flemme art pourquoi je dis
que cette flamme aller négative parce
qu'elle renforce un truc qui s'appelle
l'effet bulle voulant faire une vidéo
dédiée dites moi si ça vous intéresse
dans les commentaires
mais je ne pouvais pas ne pas en parler
ici parce que ça me paraît évident
l'effet bulle c'est le fait qu'on
construit nos fils d'informations sur
par exemple facebook
instagram twitter etc en fonction des
gens qui sont d'accord avec nous puisque
quand quelqu'un va être en désaccord
avec nous régulièrement
ça va nous saouler et on risque de virer
cette personne de notre fidh
donc du coup en fait on s'enferme dans
une bulle et chacun est dans sa bulle
c'est des bulles dans lesquels du coup
il ya rarement d'avis divergents et donc
quand on a la flemme de débattre bas
entre chaque bulle il ya de moins en
moins de perméabilité en fait donc les
gens qui sont dans leur bulle ont des
positions qui sont de plus en plus
radicale est donc en fait à l'échelle de
la société
c'est le clash voilà c'est le clash et
c'est à l'échelle de la société ce n'est
pas qu'en france c'est dans le monde et
je pense que l'on observe tous
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail
maintenant mais cette flemme de débattre
elle est dangereuse par rapport à ça je
trouve
et donc si je vois les conséquences
cassette flemme par rapport aux causes
qui crée cette flemme c'est à dire la
balance énergie gains j'appelle cette
flemme une flemme négative je pense pas
qu'elle soit cool cetelem
maintenant je vous parlais d'une flemme
positive que j'avais fait que j'ai perdu
c'est une flemme que j'aurais pas
qualifiés comme flemme si je n'étais pas
en train de faire cette vidéo mais en
fait dans cette vidéo et c'est encore
très bien et donc ça me paraissait
logique de l'appeler flemme mais au
moment où je la ressentais vous m'auriez
demandé vous aurez plutôt appeler ça un
désintéressement
c'est quelque chose que j'ai ressenti
après ma première retraite méditative où
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps à réduire
mon attachement et mon aversion aux
choses dans ce processus j'ai commencé à
réduire mon attachement à ce que je
ressentais mais aussi à ce que je
pensais alain disait des contient une
opinion elle nous tient alain c'est un
philosophe n'est pas alain le voisin et
alain ça fait d'offre s'appelle ses
leçons non ami alain je n'aime pas son
prénom d'air ça n'a absolument aucun
sens monsieur madame intérieure ont un
fils est ce monsieur madame
ailleurs on un fils un autre alex ouais
tu là où va donc bref cet effort a eu
des conséquences assez directe quand les
gens n'aiment pas ce que nous aimons et
nous faut élargir ce n'est pas seulement
ce qu'on aime c'est aussi ce qu'on croit
le plaisir d'aimer se mélange à la
tristesse liée au fait que les gens
n'aiment pas ce qu'on aime ou ne croient
pas dans ce qu'on croit et là on a deux
solutions soit on va changer ce qu'on
aime pour adopter le goût des autres
donc c'est à dire que par exemple on va
suivre le dernier truc à la mode ou bien
on va suivre l'opinion de politiques
dominantes qui est dans notre cercle
proche soit et c'est pire on va pas
vouloir changer ce qu'on aime
on va vouloir changer les autres on va
vouloir changer ce que les autres m ou
bien va vouloir changer ce dans quoi les
autres croient c'est un truc que spinoza
appel l'ambition je voulais un extrait
de l'éthique
trois propositions 31 cet effort pour
faire que chacun approuve ce que soi
même on aime ou à antenne est en vérité
de l'ambition et par suite nous voyons
que chacun par nature aspire à ce que
tous les autres vivent selon son propre
tempérament et tous les aspirants de
père et tous ou voulant être loués ou
bien aimé de tous ils se haïssent les
uns les autres a expliqué ça vous fait
du bien qu'on reparle de fille lola de
la bonne file au sur cette chaîne sauf
plaisent moi aussi moi aussi moi aussi
un petit peu mais pas tant que ça ça
nous fait plaise mais je ça me fait plus
autant parler mais je suis inquiète pas
en parler quoi je gpad attachement
particulier au fait de vous sortir une
peau du corps aux citations bien grâce
de spinoza quoi c'est cool quand ça
arrive mais quand ça arrive pas ça me va
aussi
j'espère que comme moi vous n'y attache
pas trop d'importance donc qu'est ce
qu'on est en train de dire là parce
qu'on n'est pas sûr de ce qu'on aime et
ce qu'on croit on a besoin que les
autres
m et croit comme nous parce qu'on a
besoin d'être aimé et donc ça nous
pousse à vouloir que ce qu'on aime soit
aimée par tous et donc comme c'est
absolument pas possible tu montes fini
par se haïr alors qu'au début on voulait
juste de l'amour c'est un peu triste je
trouve du coup quand j'ai réussi à
mettre une distance avec mes croyances
mais attachement
j'avais plus eu besoin que les gens
aiment ce que j'aime ou crois ce que je
crois donc j'avais plus le besoin de les
convaincre à aimer ce que j'aime ou à
croire ce que je crois et donc mon
nombre de débats a énormément diminué
je débattais plus mais je continue à
discuter avec les gens avec qui j'étais
en désaccord quoi et ça me posait pas
vraiment de problème quoi j'écoutais
même si j'étais sûr de mes convictions
et cetera voilà c'était un point de vue
j'écoutais j'étais serein quoi et c'est
en ça que je parle d' une flemme
positive parce que elle est dans la
bienveillance en fait elle permet de
garder une perméabilité entre les
opinions
grâce au respect et à l écoute et
c'était super chouette et d'ailleurs ça
marrant ce que ça faisait péter un câble
parfois certaines personnes
parce que certaines personnes ne
comprenait pas pourquoi je n'essayais
pas de les convaincre en fait après ça
n'empêchait pas dire parfois mon désolé
je préfère qu'on parle d'autre chose ça
m'intéresse pas mais c'était pas parce
que la personne pense ce qu'elle pense
c'est juste que j'avais envie de faire
autre chose quoi tout ça pour vous dire
et j'ai failli appeler cette vidéo comme
ça et peut-être qu'elle s'appelle comme
ça d'ailleurs mais vous n'êtes pas votre
opinion dans un débat on a la sensation
de s'affirmer de prendre position de se
sentir exister on veut revendiquer une
identité personnelle mais vous n'êtes
pas une opinion mais moi non plus
personne n'est une opinion votre opinion
elle change mais vous il ya plein de
gens qui partagent votre opinion et
pourtant tous ces gens sont différentes
vous alors est-ce qu'on revendique
vraiment une identité personnelle quand
on débat non c'est pas vous qui est en
jeu c'est votre opinion et c'est deux
choses très différentes
ce détachement là dans l'écouté la
bienveillance 1,7 flemme positive c'est
un nul c'est un au nul je déteste ce
terme de flemme positive
j'ai appelé ça pour la vidéo pour que
soient plus claires venues en hard
appeler ça comme ça on appelle ça le
détachement hockey ce détachement il ya
un mois je pouvais le prôner en fait
mais ya une partie de moi que ça dérange
un petit peu en fait un petit clash
entre la sagesse de mon moines intérieur
qui est dans son temple et l'ambition
pour reprendre le terme de spinoza de
mon militants intérieur qui est dans son
agora aimons militants il dit un mot
moines mec si tout le monde a la flemme
de débattre à la société al avance plus
et montmagny répond déjà tu m'appelles
pas mec
d'accord je sais pas qui tu es pourquoi
tu as des dreads et aussi des débats qui
rendent ce détachement très difficile
parce que c'est des causes qui nous
touche directement
par exemple si vous êtes une minorité et
que vos droits fondamentaux sont remis
en cause c'est un exemple parmi tant
d'autres mais là aussi il ya une partie
de moi qui qui invite à suivre
marcorelle qui dit on rejette l'opinion
et tu seras sauvé et à une autre partie
qui a envie de faire évoluer les moeurs
lorsqu'on débat avec les autres il faut
sortir de l'idée qu'on le fait pour que
les autres changent d'avis on fait pour
mieux comprendre ses propres positions
les affiner les maîtriser et peut-être
même l'échangé lorsqu'on a eu tort parce
que les changements les plus importants
ils sont à faire en nous mais le plus
important lorsqu'on débat avec les
autres mais surtout quand on débarque
soi même ce que je en train de faire
dans cette vidéo c'est qu'il faut
accepter que parfois on n'a pas la
réponse à sa propre question
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et
partez pas de vous parler des tee-shirts
les amis vous souvenez peut-être de
clément clément c'est celui qui a fait
les musiques dans la vidéo du népal vous
avez surkiffé la vidéo du népal les
musiques et toutes on me dirait à la
musique et sont trop stylé
[Musique]
clément jérémy dans le making of du
népal du coup il disait ça par exemple
un bonjour je m'appelle clément je suis
un pote de cyrus depuis cinq ans voilà
vu que c'est un pote de longue date et
qui lancé ce projet et moi je dis que
j'ai jamais fait de t-shirts de pulls
etc
c'est la bonne occasion pour le logo
j'ai pris la bannière youtube qui m'a
fait les gars de la timone humaine tu
que je salue et il y avait ce logo que
je trouve trop stylé de points
d'interrogations qui forme un coeur pour
tous les gens comme moi comme vous
sûrement si vous regardez cette vidéo
qui aime se poser des questions donc
j'ai un peu retravaillé logo moi même et
on a reçu les échantillons hier et donc
et donc voilà par quelques éléments très
importants donc c'est que de la pré
commande donc ya pas de stock donc ya
pas de gâchis du coup vu que c'est que
la pré commande
choisissez bien votre taille regardez
bien le guide détaille sur sur le site
mais que ces genres la taille que vous
mettez d'habitude c'est du coton 100%
bio donc je voulais 10 et l'après coton
qui a pas de stock
ça a été brodé en france voilà c'est
broderie de qualité etc
c'est vraiment un truc qui tient dans le
temps c'est de la bonne came honnêtement
pour la voir j'ai le pull et le
tee-shirt et les deux c'est vraiment de
la bonne came maintenant c'est très
important ce que je vais vous dire je ne
vous pousse pas à la consommation certes
que s'il vous plaît pas d'acheter
pasticheur si vous voulez l'acheter cube
pour me soutenir
il ya d'autres manières de soutenir vous
pouvez me faire un don sur tipi par
exemple maintenant vous trouvez le
t-shirt stylet vous avez besoin d'un
t-shirt noir d'un bon basique ce genre
de choses ça me fait henin en plaisir de
vous mettre ce t-shirt à disposition et
je peux vous assurer que c'est la bonne
qualité c'est la bonne came c'est un
truc à vous duré longtemps mais voilà le
sujet de la consommation est un sujet
qui est assez important pour moi qui
devient qui le devient de plus en plus
donc je préférais vous le dire voilà
j'espère que c'est un projet qui va vous
intéresser j'espère que ça va vous
plaire c'est en précommande pendant 30
jours
je vous en reparlerai sur un stade
twitter ma newsletter et cetera merci
clément
merci pour ta patience que j'ai été
heureusement là est en train de regarder
la vidéo ici mais normal n'a pas été au
bout j'étais un peu relou comme si ça
vous plaît il y en aura d'autres avec
d'autres collections d'autres effigie
etc
on a déjà un truc qui est prévu voilà je
pense que j'ai dit ce que j'avais à vous
dire
le lien est en descriptions pour choper
le t-shirt ou le souhaitent
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
j'espère que ça vous a intéressé et que
ça résonnait en vous que ça vous a fait
réfléchir sur d'autres choses
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
dimanche 10h30 pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là prenez soin de vous non moi je
suis en live sur twitter ce soir à 18h30
et aussi mardi à 22 heures comme tous
les mardis à 22h d'ailleurs tous les
mardis à 22h chat en live sur twitter on
s'est créé un petit rendez vous c'est
hyper cool à chaque fois ya pas mal de
monde et on regarde des documentaires
des reportages et ses terrasses aussi un
coeur pour vous mes amis parce que je
vous kiffe à la semaine prochaine love
peace ciao